concerns are growing tonight after
family says their dog died from being
boarded at a northeast valley facility
the atencio family says their dog connor
passed away after they just picked him
up joe moeller spoke to a woman who's
not surprised and he's live near nellis
and lake mead with what she's saying joe
alisa gagliano heard our story and she
said she has some problems too at the
facility that's behind us here now one
animal rights activist is asking people
to come forward if they know anything
about what happened this was a buzz it
was shaved lisa gagliano says her dog
did not get the pet cuts she thought it
would from paw's ass these past
i don't know four months or so
it's just it's it's really gotten bad
she came across the eight news now story
about the atencio family shock
my heart sank that family says they
picked up their dog connor after it was
boarded at paz they claim it came back
ill missing teeth and eventually died
gagliano says it's sad to hear my own
personal feeling was just i won't set
foot in there again there are a number
of reviews for the business some good
but others from unhappy customers urging
people to not use the facility i think
what makes it even worse is that the
business is not providing any kind of
cooperation or information that has to
be so frustrating animal rights activist
anula wildrich has spoken to the family
and says there is now an investigation
into kana's death if there are any
volunteers or other people who do have
direct knowledge about this incident i
would urge them to please contact clark
county animal control she says owners
need to be careful when boarding their
dogs they can check yelp they can check
reviews
they can ask around maybe get word of
mouth referrals about the best places to
take their pets
now back out here live we did call paw's
ass and talked to the owners a few times
today and they are worried about the
threats they are receiving into the
facility but they did not want to
comment on kana's death at this time
reporting live this evening john muller
live local now